let's go next to our caller from the 206
area code who's calling today from 206.
david i can hear me yes i can who's this
pleasure to finally meet you i'm logan
rogers
originally from florida but currently
living in seattle
i love it got kind of a setup for you
thank you got kind of a setup for you
with a little bit of just i want your
opinion on something that's been
personally going on politically in my
life
but uh very recently i had a couple
friends of mine that i moved out from
florida
to move into my house in seattle and
i've known the man
for a good like four or five years and
he has a girlfriend
and we recently had a little bit of a
you know
quarrel over this whole black lives
matter protest
you and the girlfriend had a coral yeah
yeah she's she's more of a
she's from ohio and uh he's from
florida and he's got you know
progressive politics they both do
but she just couldn't get over the fact
that property damage was being
occurred because of these protests and
that she like
basically didn't really approve of it
and i made the point to her
because she was one of the people being
like you know not all cops are bad
people there's there's
a lot of good cops and i tried making
the point to her that
if you have three thousand good cops
that do good things and four bad cops
that do really really bad things and
those
two thousand cops don't say anything
about that
you still have 2004 bad cops and she
took it extremely personally because she
has
a lot of police in the family and
basically thought that i said that her
dad was a racist that kills black people
okay and they haven't talked to me in
about three months now
and they moved out and it's really
really been kind of hard on me because i
love them both
and my my political verbal skills aren't
nearly as refined as yours i must say
and i was just wondering like where
where would you take that relationship
you're saying at the point at where it
is now what would you do
yeah i mean it really depends on what
your what your goal is
is the goal to uh sort of
fix the damage that has been done
pretty much yeah i'd like to really do
that well i mean i don't know these
people it's very hard for me to say but
i would try reaching out and saying
i feel terribly about the
outcome of our relationship you don't
necessarily have to say
i take back what i said because it
sounds like you don't and in that case
you shouldn't i wouldn't lie and say you
were wrong in what you said if you
believe you were right in what you said
but you could say i really regret how
this went and would you be open
uh to talking to me i mean i don't know
that there's really that much more
that there's that much more that you can
do you can just say forget it you can
say i'm gonna wait for them to reach out
if they ever do or you can be proactive
but i don't know that i have any special
insight based on the subject matter
okay all righty well you know i'm just
trying to reach out and just find people
that you know you seem like a very
reasonable person to talk to about these
things so thank you for taking my call
um just quick little shout out i really
really appreciate you guys you and kyle
uh i'm from florida originally i come
from a very conservative background
and i was pretty racist for a long time
really thank you guys for everything you
guys do oh yeah
i was like purebred like you know get
these mexicans out the border kind of
thing
so what like yeah now get these mexicans
out
what what beliefs did you have about
mexican people
uh well you know again i was raised in
the southern conservative family so just
basically all the
normal racist tropes that you would hear
you know like
they're taking their jobs or you know
dirty you know infested people who are
just you know coming over here to like
you know
make america not white you know like i
was i was pretty bad man
i'm not gonna lie like i've come up well
i've come a long way
that's that's incredible and so now when
someone
when you run into someone that still
believes that are you better positioned
to disabuse them of those beliefs or or
not really
i've de-programmed probably two people
really that i know of that are
my really good friends oh yeah yeah my
friend in
idaho was a really big fan shapiro guy
and uh
ironically making showing him you and
kyle actually brought him around being
like these guys are much more reasonable
sounding yeah 100
was there any particular issue where
they started to be open to other ideas
like was it on
you know immigration or social issues
economics where they said oh maybe
this other set of ideas actually is
making more sense to me
specifically for just my one friend i
think it was healthcare more than
anything
interesting okay yeah
and how recent was that was that during
coronavirus or prior to
three it was pre-chronicled last year
that's interesting that's interesting
thank you well congratulations i mean
you've programmed yourself and two
people that's already more than most
people can say
so i hope that the relationship is
rekindled if that's the way you want it
to go and i really appreciate the phone
call
thank you so much david all right take
care tough situation there
that's a tough situation